en la primera visita europa del polémico
principio conocido como mbs después de
que en el año 2018 apareciera en la sede
del consulado saudita en estambul el
cuerpo sin vida del periodista saudita
disidente jamás cayó y después de que
los servicios de inteligencia eeuu
acusarán directamente el príncipe de
estar detrás de este asesinato desde
entonces mbs que dirige de facto su
reino fue aislado por los países
occidentales de la comunidad
internacional solamente en diciembre del
año pasado al presidente manuel macro no
se reunió con él en yeda arabia saudita
como parte de una iniciativa para reunir
dinero para el líbano por lo tanto la
cena de esta noche marca definitivamente
su regreso a la escena internacional
sobre todo después de que hace dos
semanas el presidente joe biden
presidente de los eeuu se reuniera con
él en arabia saudita después de haberlo
tratado como un paria de la escena
internacional que lo que buscan los
países occidentales con estos encuentros
es que arabia saudita en un contexto de
guerra en ucrania y de inflación de
precios de la energía aumente su
producción de petróleo recordemos que es
el primer equipo de crudo bruto del
mundo sin embargo no lo tiene fácil
arabia saudita pues tiene compromisos
con la opep 1 la unión de productores
que copreside además con rusia arabia
saudita tampoco ha condenado duramente a
vladimir putin como lo ha hecho
occidente a cambio que lo que busca el
príncipe dinero para financiar neon su
proyecto de ciudad futurista a orillas
del mar rojo las organizaciones de
derechos humanos francesas han criticado
que se reciba al príncipe aquí en
francia amistad internacional dijo que
francia cierra los ojos a las
violaciones a los derechos humanos en el
reyno a cambio de sus intereses
económicos reporteros sin fronteras en
cambio recordó que todavía 27
periodistas presos en arabia saudita un
país que no respeta ni los derechos
humanos ni la libertad de expresión